Con đường này từng là lối vào đội mùi một sáng mừng thân.
Sau trận lúc quát sáng mùi bày tháng bày không càng chỉ còn đất đã kê cối mùi gàn.
Chúc khi mà lúc quát đi không càng rất đẹp với em mình.
Sao ngồi đây, em mình năm năm bị chơi rồi dần dậy thì luôn rồi.
Sau nhà em em là con là rồi dế thôi, mình không đến lộn phô này.
Nó còn rất lý nước của lúc gì nữa.
Lên cả một chút, đã sổ là không thể lúc thôi.
Nó rồi, anh anh quát hế cả một con cả nhà, có cã đồ đàn trong nhà là mất hế không nghe lại thân kịp này của kỳ lý cả.
Đến sáng mùi tham tháng bày, bơ lúc tại lai châu đã khiến bướng người thiệt mạc, bốn người bất tích,
đều ở sã mừng thân và sã thân viên, hàng chúc nhà bị sập hoặc hương năng,
trong đó sã mừng thân có mở bốn hộ bị lúc quát quán sập hoàn toàn, nhiều nơi vẫn bị cô lập.
Mực lượng chức năng hưi động gần năm 2018, cùng khoảng 20分 tiện tham ra tìm kiếm kiếm kiếm nạn và khắc phục hộ quát.